what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today um i am
going to be reacting to mob deep shook
ones part two before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos um in part one i googled it i
cheated i learned that a shook one is a
person
who acts tough but really isn't so like
he says he's gangster and like cool but
really
he's just a chicken when the guns and
crime and murder starts to happen so me
i would be a shook one because i would
in fact run so
i'm gonna try to pause this every 30
seconds because there is copyright
strikes i keep getting so we're going to
try to avoid those today
yo
don't we gotta get this loot
yeah
to all the killers and the hundred
dollar
so he's saying this is to the guys
that are tough
they're not shook ones because they
don't have feelings
[Music]
off the okay we be the infamous you
heard of us official queensbridge
murderers tomorrow comes equipped for
warfare beware of my crime family who
got enough shots to share for all those
who want to profile and pose rock you in
your face stab your brain with your nose
bone you all alone in these streets
causing every man for themself in this
land we be gunning
okay so he's saying that's every guy for
themselves so you think you got friends
homies pals
no you don't you have zero
none
who's running like they supposed to they
come around but they never come close to
i can see it inside to face it in the
wrong place cowards like you just get
their whole body laced up with bullet
holes and sucks speak the wrong words
man and you will get touched you can put
your whole army against my teammate i
guarantee you it'll be your very last
time breathing your simple words just
don't move me you're minor we major
you're all up in the game and don't
deserve to be a player don't make me
have to call your name out your crew is
featherweight my gunshots will make you
levitate
okay so he's it's threat threat and
threat he is he's saying you don't
deserve to be in this game
now i wouldn't call shooting people a
game but
i guess we all play different games in
life i play volleyball and basketball
you know and they play
the gun stuff so
okay
[Music]
go figure meanwhile back in queens the
realness and foundation if i die i
couldn't choose a better location when
the slugs penetrate filler burning
sensation getting closer to god in a
tight situation now take these words
home and think it through or the next
you ever notice how in this video okay
one there's another threat he's gonna
read a rhyme about killing you
not nice um
two
you ever notice
i have never had this many friends in my
life
i like to think i'm popular you know
maybe not popular but
i like to chit chat you know make
friends
and
he has got a lot of friends like a lot a
lot of friends
this ain't no such thing
scared the deaf is scared they shook
cause ain't no such thing
scared
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
okay for every rhyme i write it's 25 to
life so he's saying he raps about his
crimes and then he gets 25 to life
you would think he would stop snitching
on himself that's the advice
i would give right
but you know
who am i to tell you how to live right
type of hesitation the only leads to
incarceration you don't know me there's
no relationship queens bridge don't play
i don't get time for your petty thinking
my son i'm bigger than those claiming
that you pack heat but you're scared to
hold it with the smoke clears you'll be
level one and you don't 13 years in the
projects my mentality is what kid you
talk a good one but you don't want it
sometimes i wonder
you're killing people
i can't i can't imagine your shot at
heaven is is good
i mean i don't know i'm not god right so
who am i but i'm just i'm a logical
person i'm a thinker
and i i would just imagine that murder
out of all the sins is like one of the
worst sins
so if you've done that a lot
i i can't imagine your odds are great
but
i'm rooting for you on that cause my
brain reacts front if you're one kid lay
on your back i don't fake dad's kid you
know i bring it to you live stay in a
child's place get you out of line
criminal monsters d4 recognition i'm
sipping e and j got my mind flipping i'm
[ __ ] digging my was out of hope for
hustling get that little kid you know my
function [ __ ] as long as i'm alive i'm
believed illegal
wait your dome was a dome get your dome
up
i don't
okay so halfway crooks so he's saying
there's no so it goes back to the shook
because the shook person is like
the guy that's afraid and so he's saying
if you're you can't be like a half crook
you're either a crook or you're not a
crook
and you my friend are not that's what
you're saying
[Music]
who did it who did
what come on
[Music]
crimes
oh my gosh
um i actually enjoyed that song a little
bit more than the last one um at least
slightly
because i like the beat a little bit
better plus
i'm a i'm
i'm a picture person so if i get like a
a video and the last one didn't have a
video so it made it even better but
um out of five i'm gonna give this a
three
so it'll be like a six on a one to ten
scale so let me know in the comments if
you guys agree or you disagree don't
forget to subscribe to the channel bring
that notification bell i'll talk to you
guys next time